You checked your phone 96 times today.
That's once every 10 minutes you're
awake. And you're not even choosing to
do it. Your brain on infinite scroll. It
looks exactly like a brain in a casino.
Same addiction patterns, same withdrawal
symptoms. But here's what they don't
want you to know. One simple habit
breaks their billion-doll grip. The 5
4321 technique. Right now, do this. Five
things you can see. Four things you can
touch. Three things you can hear. Two
things you can smell. One thing you can
taste. That's it. That's it. You just
became present. You literally can't
scroll and engage all five senses
simultaneously. Your brain has limited
RAM. When you run the sensory program,
there's no space for the consumption
program. 30 seconds of this reduces
cravings by 78%.
more effective than most professional
interventions. Tomorrow morning, before
touching your phone, try it once. You're
about to discover what your mornings
used to feel like before the algorithms
took over.